Good morning.
Morning to morning, sir. Good morning, sir.
Good morning, sir. Good morning.
Okay, we'll start in a few minutes. I,
Okay, let's just start now.
I'll share my screen.
Okay, so let just start.
So, okay, let me just,
uh, quickly summarize that what we did in the last class.
We were talking about this, uh, GRU gated,
recurrent, uh, unit,
and, uh, we understood the GRU as just an
other, other, you can say the variance of this.
RNN, like LSTM.
Okay, so R-N-N-L-S-T-M-G-R-U, these are
of the same type of network
where we process the input in a timestamp wise manner.
So it is especially, uh, you can say a good
for the sequential data, whatever sequential data you have,
where you see that the timestamp matters, okay?
That you, if you process the data with, with respect
to the time or as a time stamped manner,
then it'll have better meaning,
which is coming out of the data.
Then you can always utilize this, uh,
R-N-N-L-S-T-M or GRD.
So major differences, what we have seen in the RN,
we did not have any mechanism to store the long-term memory.
So memory concept was missing,
although we were processing the context, the context
at the current timestamp,
and then we were doing some, some, uh, linear
functionality, right, uh, uh, linear operation in order
to maintain that context.
But, but if the context is very long,
then it is very difficult for a single cell to remember
that context for long, long context.
Now that that was the problem which we solved using first
lstm, where we had the number of gates, the four gate,
gate input gate, it helped, uh, it helped to
maintain those short, short-term context as well
as the long-term context.
So in the LS tm, we were having two separate memory,
you can say that one, the long-term memory ct,
and another one is the short-term memory ht.
But in the GRU on the other hand, we said
that let us not have two different memory.
Because if you take the human as in human memory
as an intuition, that in the human memory,
we don't have two separate memory, right?
We have a single memory, obviously we do some addition.
Uh, whenever we get a new information
after a certain time, we forget some of the event,
what we have, uh, what we have per, uh,
what we have done our lives.
So those addition means forgetting
and addition that that is happening all the time in,
in our human brain,
but we do not have two separate memory
for the longer context or short context.
Uh, the same idea, same idea. The GRU uh, has proposed.
They said that, okay, separate memory cell is not required
for long-term context.
T itself can maintain both the things,
and hence we had this reset gait and update gate.
So reset gate was deciding, okay, how much
to forget from the memory, whatever state
of memory we have right now.
And update GATE was helping to make a balance between the
old memory, what we have as of now,
and the new memory, what we are getting now.
Okay. So between tho these two, how to make a balance
and create a altogether new memory state about the GRU.
So this is what we have done so far. Okay.
So if you have any quick questions, if you, uh,
you can ask me, then we will move on to the next topic.
Yes, sir. Hi, good morning, sir.
So for GRU, we need, uh, little less, uh, length
of contest when compared to LSD.
I was thinking about the use case.
When we have longer, uh, context length,
then we will use L SST M,
but the context length is small than we can use GRU instead
of uh, uh, no, uh, GRU instead of LSTM.
Am I right, sir? My understanding is correct.
See, I would say based on the sequence length,
let us not compare these two now,
because the, the idea is the RU
and LSTM both can handle the longer context.
Yes, sir. Yes. So sequence wise,
let us not differentiate these two
and, uh, you, you can try any of these network
and in fact, both of them
and then see that which one is performing good.
Okay? Only thing is that if you, if you want
to compare them, you can compare in terms
of the complexity, okay?
How many parameters we have in LSTM or GRU
and which one is lighter as compared to other.
So GRU is lighter
because number of less number of parameter.
Yes, sir. But sequence lengthwise,
that is the capability of the network.
Or you can say the power, the power of GRU
or TM is both, both are same.
I mean, I would not say one is, uh, more than other. Yeah.
Yeah. The way is that we need to compare the mattresses
of both output is both our accuracy.
Yes. Then you can always, um, take a call that, yeah,
GRU is performing here, good, or LSTM is not, or
unless you don't do the experiment, it's very difficult
to answer that.
You should start with both
experimentation and then take a call.
Yeah, sure, sir. Thank you.
In, in terms of accuracy, is there any difference,
uh, LSTM and GRE
In terms of accuracy?
So is there any difference between LSTM and G?
It is, it is. Uh,
obviously there might be slight difference.
I mean exactly. They may not give you, okay,
90 percentage Ls, LSTM is giving you 90% GRU.
Exactly. It'll never be, you know, that they,
they're doing some internal calculations and so on.
Mm-hmm. There might be slight difference,
but you won't see the much difference in the sense one is
90, another one is 80 for the same number of hydration,
for the same data size.
This one's difference, you may not see. Okay.
So they will be almost at the same level. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. So only the complexity based on
the complexity data sector.
Yes, yes. That is the only, that is the only thing, yeah.
Okay. Alright.
So, uh, let us move on to the next topic.
The next topic is the sequence to sequence model. Okay?
And, uh, I'll start with some motivation
that why this model was required at all.
We had already seen three different types
of network neural network.
I'm talking about that a NN, the fully connected network,
the CNN, where we had the convolution
and the pooling layers,
and then the RNN
where we had processed the input in
a time stamp wise manner.
So in the first case where we had used this, uh,
Uh,
okay,
In the first case where we had used the a NN as a network,
so it was more suitable for the TABLER data,
we talked about it, right?
So if your data has the fixed length input, for example,
you have only two features,
and this features number of features is not going
to change whatever.
Uh, however, I means whatever will be the size of the data
means here I have three rows.
Next ca I can have a hundred rows, doesn't matter.
But every time I will have only two columns.
IQ and C, GP as an input means my feature is not changing.
In such cases in an, uh, in n is, uh,
good to start, right?
Another, uh, characteristics of the, uh, ENNS, no,
no ordering or temporal dependency in the sense in your data
set, suppose you do not have any ordering
or temporal de dependency, okay?
That first, unless I do not process the first row,
I cannot process the second row.
So this kind of dependency is not there.
Temporal dependency as well as column wise.
Also, there is no ordering whether I, uh,
process CGPA here IQ here, or vice versa.
I mean, doesn't matter. I'm going to get the same output.
Okay? So if the ordering is not important,
if the dependency is not there, then again, even it's good
to start with.
And obviously in that case, your inputs are, I mean,
the features are independent.
So this is the case of a NN, this is the case of a NN
where you have the tablet data, no temporal dependency,
no ordering, okay, you can go ahead with the a NN
and that is what we did initially when we started the scores
in the initial sessions.
My, my examples, the dataset was something like this, okay?
And then the network was also a NN.
This is a fully connected network
and we know that, how does it work?
But slowly, when we moved on
and we started using this image dataset, we found
that a NN may not be a good fit for that.
Why? Because image is always in the two DMI type two
dimensional, okay?
2D, but this a NN always accept 1D data.
So if at all, I will have to process the image with the
a NN, first of all, I need to convert this 2D into 1D.
As soon you will do that one,
you will lose the special locality information.
The neighborhood pixels are very important in the case
of image and the pitch features,
which you're extracting from those nab neighboring pixels.
That makes the image, uh, identity identifiable
at a as as a particular object, right?
But as soon you convert this 2D as 1D, you will lose
that information and hence it'll, uh, it'll,
it'll be very difficult for the a NN to identify,
okay, what is that object?
That was the main problem. And hence we, uh,
and another problem was
because you will convert this 2D into 1D,
then you will have those many number of parameters.
So suppose it is say that, uh, image is, uh,
five across five, so 25 into whatever, uh, say that, uh,
neurons you will use those many parameters it'll use, right?
But in the case of CNN doesn't happen,
you decide a filter filter size is usually very small,
three cross three, four, cross four,
and that is the weight in the CNN, right?
And then that weight is common
for the entire convolution operation.
Now, you may have some more filters also,
but for a particular filter, the weight is common for,
for the entire image,
and hence, it is able to understand the neighboring pixels
well, okay, so that was the benefit
of using the CNN over a NN with the,
when we were using this image data.
And finally we were talking about this RN and LSTM and GRU,
and we said that if your data is sequential, like X one,
the next two, the next three, like, uh, the case of, uh,
the case of text where deep, then learning then models.
So these words are coming one after other,
and hence they're making some sense.
And that same order we want to maintain at the time
of processing this particular sentence.
In such cases, the RN
and L-S-T-M-G-R-U are the one which,
which should be your choice.
Now, these three cases we have understood,
I guess quite well, that now there won't be any confusion
that, okay, this is the data what to use, right?
You can always make a call
and internal architecture, everything, you know.
Now in, in, in detail back propagation.
Also we have seen in detail for all the network.
Now, the point is now there is a new case, new cases
that so far, uh, this case is extension
of the RN lium only the, the case of sequential data,
obviously, but now the complexity is a little higher.
The complexity is that my input is a sequence, say
that I love machine learning, okay?
Say that I love machine or I love machine learning. Okay?
There is one word missing here. There is one, okay?
Okay, some word missing here, but you can understand, right?
So what is happening is that, uh, it is a case
of sequence sequential data.
So hence you can take a call that, okay,
R-N-R-N-N can be a good, good, uh, uh, you can say network
to build for this kind of data.
But soon you will realize
that here it is not just one sequence.
There are two sequences.
So I am going to feed one sequence to the RN model,
and I am going to get a sequence from the RN model.
So it is a case of many to many.
I talked about the RNN types, right?
You're feeding many inputs in a time stamp wise manner,
and you're getting many outputs in a timestamp wise manner.
So this is the case. Now, this case we have not yet handled
in, in, in any of the networks, what we have seen so far,
this particular case, we have not yet handled, okay?
And this case is special, and this case is
a little complex as well.
Why? Because, uh,
unless you, first of all, you need
to have some structure in which you first process
the input sequence, which is, I love, say machine learning.
Then first you will process.
I then love the machine learning, which we know RNN, rest,
TMG, you can do that one.
Now, so far, what we were doing
after processing this, uh, all the three inputs,
then whatever or output you are getting at the final
timestamp, that final timestamp output, you are, uh,
then comparing with the ground growth
and calculating the loss, and then optimizing your network.
Okay? But now that is not the case in the final timestamp.
Final timestamp, you don't have to give the output.
The H one is the first timer stamp as two second time stamp
as three third timer stamp.
Now, S3, I don't have to give the output.
It means I have to start the output at S3,
but the output is also a sequence.
And hence, while giving the output, also I have to go
as a time stamp wise manner.
So first time I'll give, say that the word.
Then next time I'll give the word as person,
and then next time I'll give the word as he.
Now, this is the, a little, little complex.
You can say that the case of this RNN, okay?
Or handling this sequential data.
So, uh, uh, if you see it, it is looking very simple that,
okay, I'll have a sequence which I can process the way I
have processed it in RNN,
and then I will have another sequence at the output also,
which I can process in the same way time
stamp wise, minor, right?
So typically, uh, I mean, uh, it, it looks simple,
but then there are certain problems in this, and we'll talk.
Now in this particular class, I'll go into the detail
of this particular architecture, right?
And then we'll talk about first of all,
how this architecture works end-to-end,
and then what is the advantages?
What is the disadvantages?
And then finally, we are going to see the demo also
for this machine translation case today.
Okay? So that's the plan I had. Okay, so let us start.
So in 2014, this architecture was given sequence
to sequence modeling just for your, uh,
uh, knowledge.
And let me just open that paper.
You can always go through it. Okay?
So this was the time 2014, again, when,
when this network was proposed sequence
to sequence learning with neural network.
Now, before this time, we did not have the sequence
to sequence kind of network.
Obviously, this network has used the RNN as a base
to build this architecture,
but this was, this idea itself was very new, that
representing the sequence to sequence model as a encoder
and decoder architecture.
So this, this idea was very noble, okay?
So you just have one encoder which will works
for the input sequence.
You have a Dakota, which will then decode the input
sequence, which you have got as a vector.
Okay? I'll talk about that.
Now, why this, why this requirement had come at all, okay?
You may think that, okay, why people think like that?
What was the requirement? So one requirement you can clearly
see on the screen machine translation is one of the, one
of the use case for which this kind
of architecture is very much required.
Otherwise, it is very difficult to do the translation. Okay?
You can say that why it is required.
I could have done it using only the encoder
or whatever LS TM network we have learned so far.
So every time when I'm feeding, I,
I should have got its corresponding output.
Same man. Okay?
Then when I'm feeding m then I should have got it
corresponding output, whatever it is, right?
And then foregoing whatever is the corresponding output.
Now, see, you saw the, you, you can argue that one,
but quickly you will realize that this is not the right way.
Why this is not right way,
because now you are not doing the
translation of whole sentence.
If you do like this. Time is stamp wise manner, you want
to do the translation, which you can do no problem.
But then that translation will not be correct. Why?
For I, it may give you the correct output, ma,
but for m suppose the output is who suppose, okay,
then ma, who,
and going, now you understand that, right?
First of all, for every input,
there won't be a single input, single output, right?
And secondly,
because you have not yet processed the entire sentence,
it is very difficult to give the word by word output
because you can't.
You see that, right? I am going in English in Hindi,
Maha, first of all, going, has come in between
and going is now represented by two different words, Ja
and raha and m has come at the last.
So it is not the case, like m
or m translation is at the, this time stamp itself,
I can give it is this is not the case, okay?
So the ordering in which you are giving the translation
for the target language can be completely different,
which in this particular case, you can see
that it's not like word to word translation.
I'm doing, I'm doing the translation
for the entire sequence.
It is only possible once you process the entire sequence,
have the knowledge, okay, what is the sentence?
Start translating it one by one.
Hence this encoder decoder architecture
or sequence to sequence architecture is required.
Okay? Now talk about the summarization, the other case,
okay, you have a very big paragraph
and you are, you want to summarize it in say,
three sentences we do with the charge GP nowadays, right?
Again, once you have to summarize it, how you can summarize,
you can't summarize like, okay,
I'm processing the processing.
Uh, because it, it is possible
that your paragraph has 50 words
and your summarization will have only 10 words.
So if suppose paragraph has 50 words,
you will have 50 timestamp,
because this timestamp goes by the length of your input.
So if your input paragraph has 50 word,
how many times stamp, you'll have 50,
but output how many you want.
You don't want 50 output here, you just want 10 outputs.
A summarized version of 50 words, there is 10 words.
So for 50 words, you just want 10 words as an output.
Then which timestamp you will consider
as an output which timestamp you want to skip in
between, okay?
You don't have any answer for all these things.
And hang, hence again, the right ways.
You first learn the entire paragraph once,
store it in some vector,
and then start unrolling that vector one by one.
And then here you go only for 10 times time.
Hence, you will summarize this whole context into 10 words.
Same thing for question answering.
You have to process the question first,
and then you can give the answer.
Now, see that there are lot of such cases, lot of such cases
where you have this many to many kind, many to many, uh,
case, uh, kind of scenario, right?
And the why, the sequence to sequence
or encoder decoder architecture is required
because these sequences length are not safe.
It's about their length are same,
then it would have been very easy.
Decoder is not required at all.
You can simply process encoder
and can get one output for that.
Because the main problem is if my encoders
or input sequence length is three,
my output sequence length can be four.
If it is 10, it can be three.
I mean, there is no dependency
between the input sequence and output sequence.
It can be anything. And hence, this one
to one architecture will not support that scenarios.
And hence you should have the encoder decoders
or of architectures.
This is the main reason, right? So, and how does it work?
Now, by this time, you must have understood,
because now we have to do, uh, we have to take one sequence
as an input and then give another sequence as an output.
You first have to process the input sequence completely in a
time stamp wise manner using L-S-T-M-G-R-U-R-N, whatever,
it's, and then you have
to store whatever the output you're
getting at the final time.
Stamp that. We say it as a context vector.
Why context vector? Because I am going is a context
and representing them as a vector.
So this one I'm saying as a context vector, right?
And now this context vector will be the input
for this LSTM along with the start token.
For the first time stamp
or zero time stamp, you can say that, okay?
And it'll produce the first word.
Then once it is producing the first word,
then it can produce the second word based on the first word.
And then based on the first two, two words,
what it has produced, now, it,
it can produce the third word and so on.
Now, you can, can see that this is how the, uh,
entire decoder part works.
So decoder usually works as a auto regressive fashion, okay?
You can recall, right? Auto regression,
we talked in the case of language modeling.
So language modeling, how does it work?
So you feed one input, you get the output.
So one by one, then you get this output itself here,
me here, and then me is giving you the output as j.
So then me and J you will feel as an input.
Then raha and raha.
Who, who, and that is how it is going to be.
And this is how the sequence to sequence model works. Okay?
Now see architecture wise, uh, in the sense that what is
inside the LSTM that you know already, right?
That what is happening in each time. Stamp input gate four.
Gate gate or put gate that we are going, not going to again,
uh, uh, discuss that
because that, you know, the only thing is they have used the
same LS TM or C-M-J-R-U, same RNN.
And they have, they have created this encoder sort
of encoder decoder sort of architecture,
which has made it possible for, for, uh,
converting one sequence into another sequence as a case
of machine translation or summarization, question answering
or anything else as well.
Okay? So this is the main idea
of the encoder decoder architecture.
So what I, yeah, sorry to interrupt, sir.
Uh, sir, can we go to the previous Yes.
This one, sorry, in the decoder part, uh, uh,
input should be I am.
Then it'll give the major around the,
Uh, so that, that's what we don't have, right?
Because, uh, that that is not the way we do
because I am going,
that is already encoded here in the context vector.
Yeah. So this context vector has that knowledge
that I have processed.
I, I have processed m and going,
It should be sir, uh, embedding no
iCal value embedding converted to,
Yeah, this is a con converted, uh, this context factor is,
uh, embedding or you can say
that the numerical value. Yeah.
Yes, sir. So that also I'm giving as an input,
and this is start from where I'm starting the decoded.
That is also one of the token. Yes.
'cause you know that L-S-T-M-R
and GRU always takes two inputs.
The current estate input and last hidden estate output. Yes.
The last hidden estate is acting like here.
Context vector and current estate input is the start here.
Yeah. Okay. Sweet. Okay.
Yes. And then what, and then what happened?
This, this same context vector, you see
that it travels at a second time, aamp.
So obviously there are certain changes you,
you can now remember, right?
The CT in the L sst M
Yes Is one of the context vector
and CT is traveling all the time.
Stamp all the way up to the last.
Obviously there will be some changes in the ct.
You will add something, you'll delete something in the
forget input kit, but then CT is still traveling like this.
Yeah. Okay.
And one more thing just for the clarity, you know
that L sst m always give two outputs, one as ct,
one as a ST?
Yes. There are two outputs.
So the both the context vector it is there.
So when I say context vector, it is not a single vector.
It is actually the two tensors you are getting.
I'll show you when I'll code and the time.
I'll show you that it is coming like that.
Yeah, sure. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
Others? Do you have any query? Yeah.
Okay. So now we'll,
we'll go into little detail that, uh, we'll take the case
of machine translation.
Um, so for that one here, I have taken two different, uh,
in my corpus, I have only two, two data points.
Now, when it is a machine translation, you should have the,
uh, source, uh, sentence and the target sentence, right?
Source and target. Why,
why I say the source language support is English.
So your sentence is say, I am going
and corresponding Hindi sentence should also be there in
your, in your corpus, okay?
Because then only you are going to do the loss calculation
and then going to optimize all those weights and all.
So it is going to be supervised
because your labels are available here.
So Hindi sentence is acting as a label,
but rather than just having one value in, in case
of classification or regulation,
we have seen right here we have a sequence as a label.
Similarly, suppose there is second sentence,
just one word think.
Then it's, it's, uh, Hindi sentences is such.
Now that's all. So say that I have these two
sentences in my entire corpus right now, just
for the example.
So input and output are both sequences.
Length may vary, may be different as we can see here.
Three input length
and four output length for the first data.
Then one input length, one output.
And that is also possible that length can be same
or can be different, but you don't know what it'll be.
So you have to process it in, uh, in such a way
that it should support both the cases.
Okay? Now, languages will, I'll show you that, uh,
these languages, English will have its own vocabulary,
and Hindi here will have its own vocabulary.
Let us see that one. So first of all,
what we do at the step number one, as we do always,
because it is a text data,
you can't feed to the model as it is.
So hence you have to do the tokenization.
Tokenization, you know very well. What is the meaning of it?
Suppose that is a sentence I'm going,
then you will separate i,
you will separate m you will separate going,
and hence you'll have three tokens coming out of it.
And there is one more sentence here.
Think so from think you will get one more token think.
Now, because here the corpus is very small,
all the four words are unique,
and the four words together is making your vocabulary.
So your vocabulary, you have only four words here, okay?
Now this is the vocabulary for the English corpus
or source language.
Now, you also have to do the similar job
for Hindi tokenization, okay?
Now, Hindi tokenization here I have five words
like maja, raha.
So these all will come as a tokens in Hindi,
and then you are going to create a
vocabulary out of that one.
So now you have created one vocabulary for English
and one vocabulary for hin.
Okay? This is very easy. We have been doing this one
from long time.
So you see that while creating the vocabulary,
we also do the indexing.
So in the English vocabulary, I have only four words.
I have given one, one index number to each of them.
In the Hindi vocabulary, I had five words, five tokens,
but I have added two more tokens.
The start token and the stop token.
As you can see in this particular network,
the decoder always start with the special token start
of the sentence, and it always end with the special token.
That is called end of the sentence.
I'll show you that in the demo as well.
That you need two extra special tokens for the decoder.
That is not required for the encoder
because encoder, you know that what is the, uh, length
or, uh, what is the total length of the sequence.
And those many times you'll process decoder.
You don't know at the time of the inference, you don't know
that because how many words it'll work.
The decoder always works at auto regression
that it takes the previous input gives you the next output.
Next word, prediction task. How many words has to predict?
It has to take a call.
That will, it'll learn anyway, but then when it, uh, then
whenever it has to stop, it'll stop with some token, right?
Otherwise, if it is giving any token as, as a, you can say
that the output that can go next time a stamp as an input,
and it'll try to give you the next token as an output.
But whenever end token will come,
the decoder will understand that this is where I have
to end generating the next word and it'll stop here.
Similarly, why a start token is required
because you have to start with something decoder.
You know that, how does the decoder work
or auto regression works?
It takes the first input
and then it gives you the next word as an output.
But when you're starting the decoder,
there is no first word,
there is nothing you have right now in your hand.
You have the context vector, which is coming from the as a,
as a last hidden state output.
But current input you don't have anywhere.
You have not yet generated anything.
You have not yet generated anything. He the start token.
So these two special tokens are required to initiate theod
and two, uh, stop the Dakota, okay?
And that's why I have added in my vocabulary.
These two tokens are also start is, uh, here it is shown
as the zero index
and a stop is shown, uh, given as six index.
Okay? That's all. So indexes are language specific.
You have to remember, you may say that, sir,
here the indexes are, um, not unique.
For I also you are giving one for mail also,
you're giving one, you're correct,
but then it is a language specific vocabulary.
Whenever I have to process in quarter,
I will give the vocabulary of English.
Whenever I have to process the decoder,
I will give the vocabulary off Hindi.
So that's how these two will be completely separated,
and they don't have to, they will not interact
with each other anytime, so that they have to, uh,
they will, there will be any kind of confusion.
Okay? So it's a language specific.
So now you know that what is the next step?
One hot ENC coding. So first of all, whatever
sequence you have, you will create the sequence of indices.
Like I am going, is now represented as 1, 2, 3.
And then while feeding it as an input
to the LSTM in the encoder, I will be feed fed
as one hot vector, 1 0 0 0 y 0 0 0 4 dimension.
Because vocabulary size is four.
So per vocabulary size is 10,000.
This one half factor will be 10,000.
Similarly, M four dimension going four
dimension, likewise.
Okay? Now there will be,
this is the first sentence I am going.
Next sentence will be think for that.
Also, you can represent as four dimension, okay?
Which is not shown here, but you can understand it, right?
Similarly, the corresponding target language in the,
the sentence is then the first index is given.
For a start you can see one hot vector means zero index,
and then one is given for man j raha stop.
So now this is a seven dimensional 3, 3, 6, 1 7,
because seven two are there.
Okay? So this is how you have to start with.
This is how we will start. This one hot vector
will feed to the network.
Oh, sorry. Now you see that. How does it work?
So now what I will do is I will start training
because my input is ready.
I have done the pre-processing
and now I have to start first with the encoder.
I'll get the context vector
and then I'll do the decoder part.
Okay? So in the encoder, you know that, how does it work?
It just the LSTM network.
So you have to process the entire
sequence in a time stamp page.
Now here I have only three times stamp, I am going,
so X one will be IX two will be M and x three will be,
or XT will be going, that's all.
So here you can see that at the down that, uh, um,
here you can see that, right?
So I is fed as a one hot vector point
and just a second.
So,
Okay, Here,
Uh, why?
Anyway, so I, I fit J one hot vector, then m then going,
okay, it's very simple to understand.
We have been seeing it, uh, uh, since the RRNA network.
So now what will happen at the end of the encoder,
you will get a context vector.
As I said, LSTM always give you two output.
One is ct, another one is st.
Remember the LS TM cell architecture, right?
One is the upper line and one is the lower line. Okay?
So this context vector will have two different vectors.
So two different sensors.
One will represent the CT memory cell.
Another will represent the ht, okay, the output
of the previous timestamp.
Now, these two vectors will go as an input to the L SST M
because if it gives the two output,
LSTM also accept the two output from the backend
or from the previous timestamp, right?
So that's where that, that is what it'll come from here.
Now at the decoder time stamp, what will happen,
you'll start with the start token always.
So one hot vector for the start goes to the LSTM.
Now at the decoder time stamp, for every time stamp
after the L SST m, you'll put one,
you will put one fully connected network.
You can see that fully connected network,
how many neurons you will keep here.
It'll be equivalent to your vocabulary size
of Hindi corpus Hindi, because now your work is,
or decoders work is to produce the Hindi word, okay?
And the Hindi translation. So how many neurons here?
I had a seven because you can see vocabulary IG
7, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
hence 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 7 neurons.
I will keep seven neurons I'll keep, okay?
And then you will obviously put the soft max
to get the probability distribution here.
And then whichever priorities higher, you will map it
with the corresponding index number.
And then you can say that, okay, for a start,
the first word, what is giving, uh, as an input is,
man, okay?
Now, now then you will move to the second time stamp.
You remember that these are all,
what you're seeing on the screen is happening at a time
stamp as wise manner.
All of these are not available
for you when you're processing a start.
This timestamp, these are nothing is available.
Once you got this output as a first timet stem,
then you will go for the second timestamp.
Now, here is a trick.
Here is a trick in the sequence
to sequence modeling training.
And this trick at the training is known
as teacher forcing, teacher forcing.
What is the trick? Trick is
that when you are doing the training of the sequence
to sequence modeling, there is a chance
and there will be a high chance.
I will show you that there will be very high chance
that whatever the, the, the model is generating
that is wrong, that is wrong.
For example, here for the start, it has generated me,
which looks correct here
because for i, it should have been me.
So which looks correct translation.
But look at here for me, what is, what it is generating?
It is saying that who, which is wrong, which is a wrong,
uh, translation.
So it should have been man,
but it is giving man rah, which is a wrong translation.
So what we do at the training time, we know that
that network is learning.
So it, it is very high, uh, chance
that it'll do initially many wrong predictions that
what is going to be the next token in the translation,
it'll do the wrong prediction.
It is very obvious, right? Because it is learning that.
So what we do, we,
we do the teacher forcing, teacher forcing say that
it'll still be the auto aggressive.
It'll still be the auto aggressive.
But my input for these decode you can see each time stem
will not depend on what output I'm getting
for each time stem, for example.
See here, luckily I'm getting ma as an output,
but here this ma,
when I'm feeding this ma is not depending on whatever it is
coming here, okay?
Just listen this particular point very carefully in the auto
regression, what happened in the
auto regression, what happened?
You process, first word, you get the output.
Whatever output you get here, you feed it
as an input, right?
And then whatever output you're getting at the second time,
stem will go as an input to the third time stem
and whatever output you get at the third time, stem will go
as an output for the fourth time stem.
This is called auto regression, okay?
And this is how all the LLM works.
All the language model works, right?
But then here it is slightly diff uh,
a slightly different idea
because this is, this is very much possible that okay,
your output may go wrong, okay?
Because you're training your network, right?
Hence what you will do is you will not feed the input
of these timestamp in the decoder
as you're getting the output,
you may get the output correct,
you may get the output wrong, but
because your label is available, see the label label
for I am going is it is available in my corpus,
it is available in my corus, right?
The ground truth is available.
So my input for the decoder will be as per the ground,
it'll not be as per the output which I'm getting here.
And we are forcing this one to happen.
And hence this is called as teacher forcing method.
This is called teacher forcing method. Okay?
Now this all this is only true at the training time, okay?
Because quickly you can say that those are,
if you will always feed the correct input,
then there is a high chance,
but model is not giving you the correct output
input you're feeding correct.
But at the test time, you will not have this ground truth.
Obviously test time, you don't have test time.
The model has learned and it is doing the
prediction on its own.
So I don't have the ground truth,
hence it has to depend always.
The last time aamp put only test time,
the teacher forcing is true only for the training time,
not for the testing time.
Okay? So this is what happens.
So at the training time, first we feed the start,
get the output, irrespective of what I'm getting here,
maybe correct may not be correct, I'll feed man,
then I get some output irrespective
of what I'm getting here.
I'll feed j then I'll feed raha
and why I'm feeding in this particular sequence,
because that is my ground truth, it is given in the data.
So Maha, who that I'll feed at one
by one time stamp wise manner, irrespective
of what I'm getting here.
But obviously once I process the entire sequence,
what I will do, I will calculate the loss,
I'll calculate the loss that, okay,
whatever I'm getting here as a probative distribution
and whatever was the correct output.
Like for example, let us see here, here it is, correct math,
it should a correct, correct output.
So loss should be less for this one.
But it is a wrong output. It is correct, it is wrong.
Likewise, for every output you will calculate this
categorical cross entropy.
You can, uh, remember, right?
Each value here in one hot vector will get multiplied
with the probability what we are getting from Softmax.
Okay? And that will add here,
that we'll add here, that we'll add here.
That will finally, you are getting the submission,
the collective loss,
which is coming from the whole sequence in the decoder.
And based on the loss, you start the back propagation.
You first do the back propagation in the decoder,
that will again go back in the encoder.
So you see that very complexity, right?
So first of all, the process itself is very, uh, the
for forward propagation itself is very, very, uh, slow.
That time stamp wise manner, you have
to first process encoder and then decode,
and then it comes the decoder, uh, sorry,
the back propagation part again, you have
to do all the back propagation through, uh,
back propagation in the case of, uh, decoder
and back propagation through time in the encoder.
So this is how the training completes.
And in the training time, as I said at the output,
you will apply the soft max here
at the fully connected layer,
the output you will apply the soft max
and uh, you have the ground truth.
So you have yt cap yt
and you calculate the loss between them.
This you have done many times early also.
So hopefully you will. Uh, so here also you have a vector
of seven values here also you have vector of seven values,
element wise, multiplication and addition.
You do, and that is how you get the loss, loss
for a particular timestamp.
And then you do for second, you store it, do
for the second time stem, also store it third time stem
store it, fourth, fifth, add all of them, okay?
And that is how you get the total loss, right?
So this is, this is how the training of the, uh, encoder,
decoder, uh, network happens.
Okay? Now, uh, let me know,
let me know if you have any query in this one first, that
how does it work at the, in quarter time,
I'm sorry, training time.
So, uh, this home, which is, uh, not correct,
how it is rectified going for this.
So multiple duration it takes and maximum probability
Takes in, correct?
Correct. See, the idea is same idea is not being changed.
That once I'm putting the fully connected network here,
putting the soft max giving me the probability, yes, sir,
whichever priority is highest, I'm just matching, uh, the,
converting them as one hot vector
and that is my next word or being predicted.
Here it is,
it may be a correct word prediction, it may not be.
I mean, but the idea itself, I'm not changing it is true.
But what happened once you do it for a hundred
thousand times training slowly, it start adapting slowly
and has started giving you the correct, yeah, yeah, sure.
Thank you. Yes.
Okay. So we understood right that
how the teacher forcing is working that
and the, at the time of decoder, the inputs
of the decoder is independent of the output of
what they're getting at each time stamp, okay?
So you are forcing the input to be correct.
Now, see, this is not compulsory.
You can make it independent also,
and you can argue that sir, anyway, you are training
that one anyway.
You are training this network. So hence maybe
you're doing sub iterations.
It'll adapt that also.
And you are correct if suppose you're thinking in that way.
You are absolutely correct.
So teacher forcing ensures that
your convergence should happen fast.
Why? Because suppose you're feeding the correct input.
See, you don't have any control on the output
unless you have not trained the network.
It'll go wrong and it'll go very, uh, uh, go wrong in every
time stamp also in the initial iterations.
But because you know the ground rules, you don't want
to feed the wrong input.
So how will it help? It'll help to converge you faster.
What will happen if you not do this one in this way
and you depend on the last hidden state output,
it'll still converse.
But suppose here it is taking thousand titration,
it may take 2000 titration, okay?
I'm just, uh, just, just a number of which I have thrown,
but it'll take more time.
Teacher forcing is the way of, of, uh,
at least feeding the correct input.
So let us not feed the wrong input, okay?
And then network will put the effort
to learning the weights here to get the correct output
because input is being fed every time correctly.
Now, suppose input is also wrong, then it may have
to learn it even, uh, even more number of hydrations
and maybe there is a chance
that it'll converge and it'll converge.
But yeah, that is what is the reason why we do this
forcing, okay?
But that we don't do at the, at the inference time
that we don't do at the inference time or the test time,
because test time, the target is not available.
Say that I am going and I don't have this corresponding
measure, or it can be like, uh, anything else.
So what I'm saying is if some, some other sentence
you are going then okay, re that is not available
with me, right?
So I can't feed anything, means I can't force
to feed the input.
I have to rely on what I'm getting the output,
for example, at the test time.
Now I'm showing you, if the start is giving you map,
then mat itself will go here.
Okay? So in the, in the test time, uh, it,
it looks something like that.
It looks something like that though output,
what you're getting here, uh, at the, uh,
each time stamp will go as an input to the next time stamp.
So your network structure is like this,
although it is not shown the last time.
Uh, last state in state, uh,
last time stamp output is being the input
for the next timet time.
This is the structure of your network at the test time,
which is not there at the train time
because we are forcing the input to be my ground truth.
And this is the only change, okay?
Uh, because at the test time,
your ground truth are not available.
So we have to depend on what word I have generated so far,
and accordingly I have to generate the next word, okay?
Okay. This we have seen earlier also,
but in the case of other, other context,
but here we are seeing encoded decoded context.
That's all. Okay?
So now, uh, with this, uh, we have understood that
how the training and testing happens for in,
for the sequence to sequence model.
And we have taken the case of machine translation.
It can be some other case also like
summarization, question answering and so on.
But it is a machine translation case.
Now, uh, the next two slide I'm showing you, uh, two,
you can say that the improvements which is possible
with the sequence to sequence model the version,
what we have seen so far.
So here I was feeding the input as one hot vector,
and you know that one hot vector has its own problem, right?
The vector itself is very high dimensional
and it says sparse vector.
That many value will be zero, only one value will be one.
Okay? Possible that this vector size is 1000
or 10,000 or one lag.
All those things are possible. I'll show you.
If the vocabulary size is very high,
then this whole vector is zeros, vector
of zeros except one value somewhere.
It'll be one which is not good for the network.
We have talked about it. And then we
use the embedding layer.
So the quick, uh, the quick, uh, improvement, what we can do
with the same, uh, sequence
to sequence model is we can add the embedding layer,
embedding layer at the encoder side,
also embedding layer at the decoded side also.
Okay? And this, this helps us to first convert my,
uh, input, which is a high dimensional spars vector into the
low dimensional dense vector,
and then do the same thing what we were doing in the encoder
as well as same thing as well in the decode.
Nothing changes only the encoder layer.
It helps us to represent my input in a better way.
And hence the learning will happen faster, okay?
Learning will happen faster, network will converge faster.
You may require less number of iterations to converge. Okay?
So this is, this is one of the quick, uh, improvement.
What we can do in the sequence to sequence model.
The other other, uh, uh, possibility of the improvement is,
is you can use the stacked layer of the, uh, encoder
and decoder, encoder and decoder.
Now see the stack layer.
You remember in the case of uh, um, uh,
what we are doing at the a NN, what we are doing.
Suppose we have an input.
So two inputs, then we were putting the say,
uh, just a second.
So
Now let me see something else.
Yeah. So, uh, I have first hidden layer
where I have a neuron, say 1, 2, 3.
Okay? I can have the second layer,
I can have here 1, 2, 3, and four neuron.
Then I can have the final hit layer, something like that.
And then you know that how they're connected, right?
So fully connected network,
fine and so on.
So sorry for the bad drawing,
but then this is a fully connected network.
So what I'm trying to say, this is the first hidden layer.
This is the first hidden layer.
This is the second head layer, okay?
But then so far what we have been seeing in the LSTM,
we've always had only one head layer
if you can, uh,
sorry, yeah, you can see that LSTM only one LSTM layer.
But possible that, like we do in the case
of fully corrected network here also we do
that we can add three LSTM layers on top of each other.
One after the, like we were doing in the case of A
and n, it's a similar setting, okay?
But the only difference is now it has to be, it, it, it,
it'll internally, it'll look like this.
If you see the architecture,
now I have three L SST M layer stacked on top of each other.
Okay? First hidden layer, second hidden layer,
third hidden layer like we were doing in the case
of a n we have here also,
but now LSTM has special architecture.
It'll process time stamp one by one,
and each LS TM will give you the context vector.
Two vectors, one ct, another st that has to come from here.
Also here also here also.
So what happened in the case of decoder?
In the case of decoder, when you are you,
if you suppose you're keeping three stacked hidden layer
here, you also have
to have the three stacked LSTM layer in the decoder also
because each context vector will go as an input for
that particular layer.
You can say why all these things are required,
why only three, why can't, why have 10?
Everything is possible.
You can keep 10, you can keep five, you can keep one also.
And why? The answer
of why is it'll understand the context better, okay?
Uh, because the context vector, what is coming here, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh,
coming here will be slightly different from here.
Slightly different from here. In that in a, in a way,
what we are trying to do is we are trying
to capture the different information from my input
and then trying to feed it to the decode.
And it may help. It may help.
And there is no guarantee that three will work
or only one is sufficient.
That is all experimental that you have to hit
and try, uh, do the, uh, experimentation
and get to know that that one layer is sufficient,
or two layer or three year can also work well, okay?
But these are the another kind of possibility
that you can improve.
Suppose your model is not working well for some reason
because of the data is so complex, very long, okay?
And so on. So maybe the two layers of the LSTM three layers.
So you, but usually what I've seen
that if you will increase more than four layers
or five layers of LSTM that it work will become so complex,
so complex and it'll be too slow, okay?
It very difficult to train scale this kind of network
for very huge dataset, okay?
Because you have
to process everything in a timestamp wise manner.
And then you have three layers here also here also,
it'll take some time here also here also, once it is done,
then it'll go here, then it'll go here
and it takes a lot of time, three times extra.
It is taking here for encoder.
And similarly for decoded, we got three stack layers.
So yeah, but this is one of the, you can say
that the architectural way,
you can put some more hidden layer
and maybe it'll be able
to understand the input in a better rest.
Everything is same rest, everything is same.
Okay? So now, uh, we are moving towards the
limitations that what happens when,
where exactly these sequential sequence
to sequence model may fail.
I mean, sequence to sequence model was, was very successful,
very much successful for the machine translation
or summarization sort of tasks, which we were not able
to do in a good way before this.
Uh, 2014, this network was proposed.
But again, uh, you know
that there are always certain limitations, okay?
There is some advantage, which we have seen
that now we are able to process the variable length
sequences and input also output also many to many.
But the problem is again, the long range dependencies,
again the same problem, but in the different context,
the long range dependencies problem we have seen
with respect to, uh, say that, okay,
my LSTM is forgetting.
RNN is forgetting something like that.
Here it is slightly different context in the context
of the target sequence.
This long range dependencies problem, uh,
we are going to discuss.
So now to dis before I will go
and explain with the architecture,
just let me read this paragraph for you
and let us, uh, see that what is the problem in this, uh,
if I process this one.
So here the paragraph says that
it is about the faculty development programs.
So faculty development programs offer a double-edged sword.
On the one hand, they can hone teaching skills, foster
research, and a spark innovation leading
to higher student engagement and success.
However, poorly designed programs can be costly,
time consuming and disruptive, potentially
demotivating participants.
Finding the right balance between effective training
and respective educators autonomy is crucial
for ripping the benefits
of faculty development while minimizing drawbacks.
Okay? Alright, so now what is the goal paragraph?
All of you have read, I have read it for you.
Goal is convert this entire paragraph into Hindi
and say that I have, I have given you this paragraph,
you have read the complete paragraph and now it's gone.
Now I'll ask you, okay, write everything in the Hindi
or any language, whatever, you know, okay.
Now the real problem, real problem.
You must have now felt it right? I can do it.
It's not like I can't, uh, or you can't, uh, convert that
and convert them into the Hindi
or some other language, what you know.
Well, problem is the context for so long.
I can remember Faculty development program.
Uh, uh, it has two types of side,
the benefit also disadvantage also we talked about.
And at the last it was talking about it should have a right
balance between the faculty autonomy,
something it was talking about.
I don't remember the exact word.
First of all, very difficult for anyone, right?
Second thing that, uh, second thing, uh, uh,
if I don't remember the exact word also, that is fine,
but many things, many context.
Also overall context, I can still remember,
but many context I in between, I might have forgotten.
I mean, I can't recall because I have just read it for once.
I just read it for once
and then I, I am, I'm being asked
to write everything in the other language.
This is the real problem for the human.
This is the real problem for the human right.
Now, the same problem applies on this,
uh, sequence to sequence model.
Also, same problem applies. What is the problem?
Let us see once again. So what is happening?
What the problem is that I am feeding this entire
corpus or entire paragraph in my encoder entire paragraph
in my enc encoder.
So first time faculty will be the input.
Second time development will be the input.
Third time program, fourth time offer.
Then, uh, then double, then s then sword, then on, so on,
say that 50 words I have here, 50 times temp.
It will go, which is fine, no problem.
And then finally it'll gimme the context vector. Okay?
Finally, it'll gimme the context vector.
The context vector is same,
which I have shown you the paragraph
and I have asked you, okay,
now you recall from the context factor
and convert the entire paragraph into Hindi.
That is the context factor.
So context factor is the context, what you have just read,
which is true, but then you know,
now you must have started understanding
what is the problem in the context vector.
The problem in the context factor is
it can remember the overall context.
It might forget the minute details, which is required,
but for the translation, you need everything
to have in front of you.
The point is encoder reach the entire paragraph word by word
information is compressed in one small context vector.
What will be the dimension of context vector?
Say 1 28, say 2 56, say five 12, say 1 0 2 4.
Likewise, there will be a vector here. Okay?
Now, this entire decode, it has
to rely on this context vector.
It has to rely on this context vector.
You see that the problem right now,
I don't have the paragraph itself available
with me at the time of translation.
I don't have that. What I have,
what I have is the context factor.
And this context factor has its own problem.
The problem is it might have remembered something,
it might have forgotten something
because it has to represent everything
as a five 12 dimensional vector.
Five 12 values. That's all.
So how much it has captured this one?
How much it has not captured? We don't know. Okay?
We don't know first of all.
So there are two problem in quarter side problem.
You think about long input sentences,
sentence must be summarized into one vector.
So we are giving a huge responsibility,
huge responsibility to this context vector
to remember everything,
what you have processed in the encoder, which is very,
very high ask, okay?
It's a very high ask. Means, uh, it, the,
it's very high expectation.
You can say that it is very difficult even for the human
to remember everything just by seeing one paragraph, okay?
And just add, once I have seen, I have to remember it.
Very difficult for anyone.
Similarly for the lstm or sequence to sequence model.
Also giving that much, uh, responsibility
to this context vector that you have
to remember every detail of the encoder,
what you have processed, highly difficult for the longer
long range, uh, uh, paragraphs
for a smaller case like I'm going,
it can remember no problem
for longer paragraph, very difficult.
Secondly, early words
and late words compete for representation.
Yeah. That is what is happen inside.
That's why it is difficult
because you have only five 12 numbers
with those five 12 numbers itself, you have
to represent first word also second word, also third word.
Also, somehow you have to represent them, right?
So the early word, which came at the first time, stem,
last word, which is coming at the 50th times,
they will compete with each other for the representation
in this small context vector.
Okay? Import details may be forgotten.
So in short, too much responsibility on a single context
factor, it is not fair.
But this is what we are doing in
the sequence to sequence model.
Okay? Now, decoder, what we are doing now, there is a,
not only the problem for the encoder decoder,
there is a bigger problem for the decoder.
There is a bigger problem. What is the problem?
First of all, at the time of training, uh, anyway,
you're doing the teacher forcing.
That is one good part what you're doing.
I'm not relying on the last state and state output.
Otherwise it would've been very difficult
because context factor is, anyway, it is very difficult for,
for the context factor to remember everything.
Secondly, my output is wrong,
and whole decoder will struggle that, okay?
How to give me how to give the correct output.
It'll struggle like anything.
So the problem with the decode is
although it gets the context vector as as a context, that
how I will give the translation, but,
but the problem is that when I'm doing the first time stem,
when I'm processing the first time stem,
same context vector is coming from the backside
as an input, okay?
Which is fine. Problem comes
with when I've processed the second timet stem,
same context factor is given
or the entire context factor is given.
When I'm processing the third time stamp here in the
decoder, same entire context factor is given.
Fourth, also, fifth, also, you know,
what is the problem for the decoder?
The problem is you are giving me the whole
vector before this point.
Decode has no understanding about the context factor.
Now at each time stamp, I'm saying that, okay,
take this context vector, okay?
And this is your current input,
gimme, what is the next word?
Now, LSTM will confuse what it'll confuse in the,
in the entire context vector, how to know
that, what is the next word?
Where I have to give? There is no focus. There is no focus.
Decoder cannot focus on the relevant source word
because source word is not given.
At each time a temp whole context is given.
For example, suppose when I'm doing the translation for I,
I'm giving the context vector for I am going,
when I'm doing the translation for m
I'm giving the context factor of I'm going.
And when I'm processing the processing the word going,
I'm giving the context factor here where I'm going.
So see that what is the problem?
The, it would've been better when I'm processing, uh, the,
the first time stem, I would have the focus on I,
if I'm processing the second time stem, third time stem,
I would've given some focus on going.
And when I'm doing the last fourth timestamp,
I would have given the focus
for m then getting the corresponding language word
would have been easier.
But the problem is I'm not giving any focus
to any word in the encoder.
I'm giving whole context factor
to each time stamp in the decoder.
Now, decoder will have the problem in understanding, okay,
which source word is important in the first time stamp,
which source word is important in the second
timestamp and so on.
And this is the problem of the decoder.
The same context factor is used at every decoding step.
Decoder cannot focus on the relevant source word.
So source is encoded, okay?
So it cannot focus on a particular
source word in the encoder.
It leads to in character generic translation.
So don't, no dynamic focusing
during word generation when I'm doing the next word,
generation first time stem second.
So there is no dynamic focusing of the source
or the encoder, and hence this is the problem
for the decoder set.
Okay? You see that? What is the problem?
So sequence to sequence model is doing good.
If, if the first of all, the,
if your sentences are very small, like I'm going,
it would not get into these problems.
What I have talked about. If the is like this paragraph
or even bigger, then there will be a problems like
what I have talked about, and it'll be a very,
and apart from all these things,
the complexity is a separate problem that you have
to process everything in a timestamp five manner.
Here you have 50 word.
Here, you have 50 word, you have to wait.
That must time, you can't,
you can't process them in parallel.
All those problems are there with this kind of network.
Okay, so let me, let me just stop here for a while
to understand whether you have understood
the sequence to sequence model.
How does it work? What is the advantage
and where the problem lies?
If you have any question on that.
So that is why then it paved the way for attention.
Exactly, exactly. Yes,
Sir. Is this
a model in these format in that 2014
was actually used or that was the state?
Uh, I did not get last. There was some, no,
When this paper was published at that time, uh, between
that paper and attention,
there were like three years, right?
2014 to 2017. Oh,
No, no, no, no. There was
multiple phase in between also.
Oh, I'll take you through. Okay. Attention.
Uh, in the transformer architecture,
they proposed self attention.
But before that also, the story
of attention already started in 2015, I guess.
Yeah. So I'll, I'll tell you in between there was two years
and there are a lot of things
which happened in between them. Yeah.
Okay, okay. Yes.
Okay. So, uh, that's why you understood the problem
and people realized it
after this network has proposed,
when they process the longer content, realize this, okay,
it is not working well, but the problem is not
with the architecture problem is with these assumptions
that context tructure will take care of everything,
whatever is the length of my input.
That's the wrong assumption, okay?
That's the wrong assumption, right?
And that's why they, they, they, uh, they, the next paper,
first of all, uh, it was, it was proved that,
and with this, this, uh, figure, you can see
that the sentence length, if it is between zero to 20,
you see the x axis, which is a sentence length y axis,
which is a blue score, which is one
of the performance metrics for this machine translation
cases, okay?
Uh, machine translation cases.
So they say that the translation is good.
If your sequence length is up to 20, you can see
that this curve is growing, growing, growing.
Score is growing, growing. So blue score is good.
It, it varies between zero and one.
First of all, say that and zero and sorry, zero
and a hundred, if it is, you are taking in percentage,
and, uh, it is good.
If it is, it is higher.
So you can see that the blues score, which which is growing
as the sequence length grow blues, grows grow,
and up to 20 length of sequence
for which you have to do the translation.
It is going, going grow, going well.
But after that, there is huge drop.
You see that after almost 20, 22 words, 20
or 20 18, 19, 20 words,
if you see sentence length will still grow,
and you want to do the translation of
that in the corresponding language performance
of the model was sequence to sequence,
model performance was dropping.
Like anything, you can see that, okay,
it was coming less than zero or zero or like that.
In less than zero it'll not go,
but it'll go very close to the zero
and means very poor performance.
This is the problem. And then, uh, then
you know that the next story is attention.
They say that very simple. Uh, I'll just give you the idea.
Maybe next, next class, we'll start with this one.
That they say that, okay, when you have the core
or the, the input, uh, input, uh, length, very high,
say that this is my input, the whole paragraph, okay?
It is encoded with A, B, C, D has desk, this,
that, and all say that.
Okay? So maybe somewhere, password is somewhere in between.
Okay? So you have to focus on that part. Focus on that part.
For the other example could be, uh,
other example could be I will take you
through the same paragraph.
So just, just see this paragraph, all of you,
and now you'll realize what is the meaning of attention.
Okay? Whatever I'm going to explain,
you will understand what is the meaning of attention.
Attention is, see, the entire paragraph is in front of you
as when, as a human being, we process,
suppose you will be asked to convert
that into the corresponding language.
Say, Hindi, how will you convert it?
You may read it once, that is fine.
But then you may start decoding it word
by word or window by window.
Window by window, rather than word by word.
I'll say, I'll say window by window.
You may convert first faculty development program into it's
corresponding target language.
Then you may convert for offer then for, uh, then
for double age and so on.
Okay? You will have your own way to figure it out.
But one thing, what is important is
when you are seeing this entire screen
and when you are reading this particular sentence,
faculty development program, your eyes, your concentration
or your attention is only in this particular window.
There is a window. And you just see that when you are here,
you're able to see, you say two to three words maximum.
Although every word is in front of you, you're not able
to see the words word.
When you are seeing word, you are not able to see the hone.
When you are seeing hone, you're not able
to see the word autonomy
because your focus is not
on the complete window, right?
It is at, uh, in the complete, uh, screen.
You can only focus up to a particular word,
say two word, three word forward.
That's all right? And that is what it helps.
That is what it helps. So we always see a window
and we convert them into the corresponding target,
and then, uh, uh,
and then go to the next, uh, I say that phrase, convert
that next phrase, convert that, and so on.
This is how we as a human works,
obviously you can read this multiple times
to have the holistic understanding
or the overall contextual understanding,
the entire paragraph, then see window by window
and convert into the particular target language.
And this is what attention does, okay?
This is what the attention, attention on top
of the sequence to sequence.
Did they say that? Okay? Context factor is important
because you need to have the overall understanding
of the context, okay?
First of all, but along with that, somehow I need
to capture the attention or capture that, okay?
The first time stem I is important.
The focus should be on I rather than m
and going, when I'm doing the second time, stem,
going word is important rather than I.
And m, third word going is important again.
So somehow we need to model this mathematically,
and that is what we'll see in the next class.
Uh, but then this is what the attention did, okay?
They said that for every time stamp in the decoder,
which word
or words in the encoder are important, let us find that one.
And that is called as the attention, okay?
This is not the self attention, this is the initial version
of the attention, uh, uh, which we'll see in the next class.
So, uh, here in the entire, uh, you can say paragraph,
maybe a particular window is important for you for
that particular time stamp of the decoder.
And, uh, then next time, timestamp of the decoder,
maybe your window, which your window will shift.
It'll go some, somewhere else in the,
in the, in the entire context.
And that is what somehow we need to identify mathematically.
We'll see that mathematically also, that
how do we compute that attention?
Okay? How do we compute that tension?
And, uh, we'll, we'll extend this one in the next class.
Fine. So, uh, you can ask me questions now,
and I also had the, uh, what day, where is that?
Oh, I, I, I'll do one thing I could not explain today,
although, but then I had this, uh, demo, this demo.
You practice it. Maybe next class.
I'll start with first demo,
and then I will go to the
um, Here.
Okay? Now this one, I'll, uh, share the slide
and give you the link of this as well as dataset.
Link. This dataset again, I have got from the Kaggle,
this is Hindi to English dataset.
Okay? As you can see on the screen, uh, the, first of all,
I have read the data, I have downloaded the data from the
Kaggle, and then read here in this data, you see that home.
What is the shape of the data? One lag, 77,606.
Data samples are there. Okay? There are three columns.
That is what it is showing
because first column is index,
second column is English sentence, third column is Hindi.
And so it's the parallel corpus
for every English sentence you have in
Hindi corpus available.
I did some pre-processing, uh, I'll explain everything here.
Tokenization, vocabulary, building encoder,
encoding sentence into the index sequence,
then doing some padding, right?
All these things are required. Once we did all these
pre-processing things, then we created our custom dataset
class as usual.
Then data loader class for creating the batches.
Then you have to create the encoder block,
because in the sequence to sequence model,
you have the encoder block, then you have the decoder block,
and then you have to combine both of them so
that it'll work in sync.
So encoder block, ENC code is written,
and then in the encoder block output is always, uh,
like I was showing you right here, uh, sorry, here,
here in the context vector, when,
when I'm talking about the context vector, it is LSTM.
And in the LSTM, the way it works is it gives you CT
and ST two different tens.
And that this context vector is a two tensors
combination of two tens.
Same thing. You can see here.
Once we'll do the encoder, we'll have two tensors.
First one is the uh, h,
this ht other one is the sate context vector ct.
Okay? Then we'll go to the decoder part.
Decoder word works in the auto aggressive fashion.
So you need to add the start token.
You need to start the stop token,
and you have to write the auto regression code
of the decoder that it'll take only one word at a time,
gives you the next word and so on.
Then sequence to sequence, wrapper model,
which takes the encoder.
Also decoder. Also combine them together, okay?
Build the model on top of that, okay?
And then rest of the things, you create the training loop
and start training.
So I was just trying yesterday the night, uh,
while building this one.
Uh, so, uh, I initially tried to process the entire data
and then it, I could not do it.
It means it came simply gave me the error auto
of memory, okay?
Auto of memory error, because I was, uh,
dataset is too huge.
Earlier I was using the batch side 32 and batch size 32.
In the sense what happens, you know, that, uh,
at the decoder timestamp, I'm in coder,
there is no problem actually, but
because I'm not storing any output,
decoder timestamp, what happened?
32 input. I am processing as a batch.
So what happen every time, stamp 32 sentence,
first word is being fed, every word will give the output,
and those all outputs has to be stored, okay?
All output has to be stored.
So here, also 32 word output has to be stored here.
Also here, also here,
also here also is a huge memory you require for that.
If the BA size is 32, if it is even higher,
even more memory you require because you have to store it.
Why? You have to store it unless you don't to store.
How can you do the loss calculation?
You have to do the loss calculation
because you're doing the training.
So the collab doesn't support.
I tried actually yesterday, but it was not supporting.
So what I did, if you see now my code here, first of all,
I did the sample, okay?
If you have huge memory, okay?
If you are uh, do not have any problem with the RAM size,
good, good ram, memory size, then you can process it.
Otherwise, I did only sample of data out of one lag, seven,
7,000 at then process with the 10,000 data and it worked.
But I did few more changes from 32 batch size.
I reduced it to the eight, eight batch size.
Maximum length is also matters.
I padded every length to be maximum 20.
It was some sentences was although 1 71 2 2 18 for English
and in the, I patted everything to 20.
And then after that I could able to process it with,
with the bad size of eight, best size of eight,
as you can see here, eight.
Now this is the result of that bad size.
And uh, I trained it for 50.
Oc, when I trained, started training,
the loss was coming in thousand.
See this 6,295 loss should be near to zero.
It is coming in 6,000, but
after doing 50 oc, which took me around half an hour, okay,
on this uh, collab, my GPUT four, GPU, what I used
half an hour it took,
and finally I end up with the seven 14 loss.
Okay? So this is not good.
My model is not yet trained clearly very high loss.
And then I, when I start doing the translation, uh, uh,
inferencing the testing, this is what I end up with.
I ask, how are you?
It is saying that b, I would like to tell you, uh, about,
uh, once a child.
So you see that random words, it is showing.
So translation is not good.
Uh, and blue score,
which I have shown you in the slide also, uh, which is good,
which is reasonable.
We say between 0.12, 0.2, uh, 0.2, two,
0.3 is good and greater than 0.3, it is very strong,
which is very difficult to achieve without attention.
That is what is written here
and that is what I also observed.
I was getting just 0.5.
Uh, so 0.5 is not this 0.5, actually it is giving, uh,
uh, 0.5.
Actually it should have been between
zero to a hundred range.
Okay? So zero to 10, very weak, 10 to 20,
reasonable 20 to 30, good,
and more than 30 below score means strong.
This 0.5 is in the scale of zero to a hundred.
It is not in the scale of zero to one. Okay?
That is what you have to understand. So it was very poor.
That is what my first experience is.
I will make this, uh, uh, model, uh, this, this code as well
as this data available
with you integrating in the same slide.
You do the practice next class.
I'll start with this, this, uh, notebook itself.
I'll explain you in detail, okay?
Uh, accuracy you will definitely get, if you have a good,
good, uh, uh, machines, right?
And can train it to the full extent, say that instead
of 50 apac, like I can see that it is going from 6,000
to 714.
You train it for 100 aoc, 200, 500 aoc, right?
And differently, then you will see that there is a wonder
and you will be able to see
that the translations are coming correctly.
This is what the Google translator does
or any other translator.
What you're using is to in the backend, okay?
So code is ready, it is running, pipeline is working,
but training that is where it is lagging.
You do the practice. If you have a good, good, uh, uh,
machines, you try it by yourself.
I'll show you the internal details, uh, how this,
this whole, the whole code is uh, I have built,
uh, we'll discuss that.
If you have any query, that one fine. So let me stop here.
I'll share all these things today.
You can ask me some questions.
So what is blue score, sir?
Oh, blue score.
You see that, uh, I mean I have not explained today, right?
Correct. But it is a say that uh, the,
it is, it is like for the uh, classification for regression,
we use this MSC, right?
Minus square, okay?
For classification, we use this precision recall F score.
Similarly, for the machine translation, the tric,
which we say a blue score, okay?
So, uh, just just uh, just uh, go and check on the internet.
What is the blue score formula? You'll get to know that.
So, uh, what it does basically that, uh,
you uh, suppose I'm going ma who is a
correct sequence in the Hindi, but then it is possible
because my translation translator is not trained well,
it'll give some other sequence.
So PLU score somehow, uh, it matches that
for ma it is giving me or not.
For Ja, it is giving jaha ja,
not rah means each sequence word.
It is giving in the same sequence
what is there in my corpus or not.
Yes. Okay. So that is how it is matching
and giving you one score that if suppose measure
around your translator is also measure
around it is one blue score is one
because exactly it is matching.
Okay? Yeah. Similar of recall, I think so,
Yeah. So,
but actually the blue score is not a good measure.
You see that, I'll give you an example.
For example, if I say, are you going so Hindi
re, which is correct blue score.
If my translator is saying, are you re references?
Are you re which will give one,
but suppose instead of that, if I say re,
which is also, are you going now in
that case blue will fail, it'll say no, no, no, it is wrong.
It should have been Kia is a correct sequence,
which is there in my ground truth.
But you're saying that Kia, so multiple words are changing,
hence blue will go down.
That's why I showing I shown you blue.
If it is more than 30%, more than 30,
it is treated to be good.
Okay? Treated to be good
because you can, you don't have the exact,
because for same English sentence can have multiple
Hindi sentence as an output and all are correct
and all are correct because it say it says language, right?
Multiple ways we can say the same sentence
and that's where the blue is not a good measure,
but yeah, it is one
of the measure which we highly use. Yeah.
Yes, thank you.
Okay. Alright. Others?
I have one question. I,
so does this teacher forcing cause any issues like
because we are ex exposing so much of information to it,
correct information?
Mm-hmm. So will it lead to any issue, sir?
Uh, I don't think so. Okay.
Uh, I don't think that there will be any issue for that one.
Uh, but you can see that, uh,
I don't have the correct answer.
Mm-hmm. People, they,
they use this teacher forcing in three,
three different variants.
Either you can use it or not use it.
These two are the variant, it's up to you.
Third one is I will show you in my code.
You can also use it based on some probability. Okay?
You, uh, I actually, I have used it like that.
So basically when I was doing this inferencing, I
did the same thing, uh,
where it was 10 or it's not here.
Inference teacher forcing
somewhere it was
parameter left.
Okay, takes a Hindi token
anywhere else, uh, I don't see, uh, here.
So clip, uh, no, not clip. Clip is for something else.
Somewhere I've used it. I am not able, I'm not able to find.
So what you can do is you can put a
threshold that is also possible.
All these things are possible that if my, uh, output is,
uh, suppose it'll give the probability.
If the probability is going in in a particular range,
then only I'll use teacher posing,
otherwise I'll not use teacher posing.
So you can be a little bit flexible also in that
and all things are different.
Why, uh, all things are depend how your
training is being performed, whether are you, uh, being able
to converge or not, whether the back propagation is,
uh, stable or not.
It all depends on those factors.
So you have to do the experiment and try and take a call.
Whether you want to use it is not compulsory,
it is an optional instead, but it says that it,
you have the correct input which you feed initially.
It, the model will adapt it faster as compared
to the wrong input is being fed wrong,
protection is being done and then being update
of all those parameters. Yeah,
Understood sir. And
also for back propagation, we use BPTT here also, right?
Uh, similar to RNN?
Yes, yes, yes. Okay, sir. Got it. Thank you. Yeah.
So, uh, I have one question.
So, uh, like lium, uh,
generally it helps in remember things uh,
for a longer time, right?
But uh, still the decoded gets one, only one summary.
Is that the reason why attention is needed? Yeah.
Even after using less team.
That's what, that's what, yes, yes,
That is. And even,
uh, for this, uh, teacher train is that, uh,
teacher, uh, forcing, so during training we'll give uh,
uh, correct previous words
and, uh, during testing, we'll,
it'll use its own output, right?
Like, uh, that difference Cause any problem later
sir? Like, uh, no,
No, I, I don't think, but
because at the training time you have the target,
so you feed testing time anyway, you don't have that
because you are now translating in new sentence altogether.
You don't have the correct sequence already,
you can't feed it, right?
So that's the first of all,
but it doesn't create any problem.
In fact, it may help you to get, uh,
the training a little faster.
That is my, what my understanding is.
But you can always experiment
and check whether it is going towards any unstable training,
not converging at all,
and then take a call to not using a teacher
forcing that is also possible.
Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
So bidirectional, sorry,
bidirectional team mentioned last class, so
No, I did not, I don't know like, uh, it's little
you can you try again
because your mic, I guess it is not giving
The last class you mentioned, uh, bidirectional LS tm.
Ah,
Oh bi-directional lstm.
Although I mentioned I have not yet covered,
but you can uh, imagine
that LSTM the way I have stacked now there is a possibility
that bidirectional lstm also I can use, I have not shown you
although, but it is there in the slide.
Uh, maybe next class we, we'll try to explain
that part that how does it work? Yeah,
Sure.
Yeah.
Others Is it fine? Any, any other query? Um,
Encoder part sir? Like,
um, uh, when the encoder, uh,
finishes reading a long sentence,
if we have long sentences mm-hmm.
It gives one hot vector, like one vector to the,
the decode, right?
So if in case, uh, the sentences not very long, is
that a vector kind of, uh, overloaded? Like uh,
No, it's not one hot vector context vector
is noted. One hot vector,
Okay. Context
vector is always what you're getting from CT
and ST in the LSTM,
Oh, And that is some dense vector.
Some values will always be there.
One hot vector you feed at an input
and one hot vector is available
with you at the output when you do the comparison
between the prediction and the actual output.
But in between whatever vectors you get,
it is never one hot vector.
It is always a dense vector with some values, negative,
positive, whatever it is, but not one hot.
Yeah. Okay.
Okay then. Alright,
we'll meet on Monday and we'll continue.
First we'll see the demo for this machine translation case
and then we'll quickly now attention
motivation you have already got.
We'll only see now next how to do, how
to calculate those attentions.
And there are certain methods for that.
We'll, we'll, we'll go towards it. Okay? Alright. Thank you.
Thank you sir. Thank you sir. Thank you sir.
Thank you sir. Thank you sir.